please welcome welcome
[Applause]
thank you girls
I am so happy to be with you thank you
um you know I mean we did fever pitch
together and you know
thank you I'm just so relieved because
our my producing partner of almost 30
years Nancy javonin met a man named
Jimmy Fallon and they got married
um because the fever pitched and they
have two daughters yeah they fell in
love right in front of us happily ever
after
um can I find my favorite game with you
behind the scenes sure
behind the scenes
I am looking for an unknown fact fly on
the wall moment first memory naughty
detail I don't care let it rip Dumb and
Dumber
what I remember was really special is we
were at that hotel where they uh where
Stephen King wrote The Shining that
mounted hotel called the Stanley Hotel
is that where they end up in the ski air
Lodge oh yeah that's that's with the fur
boots yes and it's haunted and we had so
much fun as a crew just hanging out in
the in all the haunted areas did Jim
Carrey do anything to his tooth was that
real was it fake how how did the two how
did Lloyd Christmas he showed up one day
right as we were about to shoot with
that chipped tooth and we're like what
what happened he said this is my real
tooth he had a cap over it he had
chipped it as a as a kid and uh he just
thought it'd be great if it's like this
it was like absolutely
greatest detail
yeah all right another absolute
Masterpiece Kingpin the thing I remember
is when we were shooting it we'd always
be in bowling alleys and and so the crew
would be setting up a shot and we'd all
go down the far end and throw some you
know throw some bowling balls and Bill
Murray's a great bowler my brother Pizza
Great bowler uh Randy Quay is a good
bowler and Woody and I are just terrible
Carol okay give it to me Something About
Mary come on
when it when it came time to shoot the
scene where Cameron's hair was up uh she
got a little nervous that day and
thought wait a minute what am I doing
this could ruin my career I could be
known as this person and it might derail
everything that I've been working so
hard for and so we promised her that we
would shoot it that way but then we'd
shoot it a different way so uh but we
tow it to an audience and see if they
left then we put it together and when we
showed it to an audience they
it was the biggest I think it was the
biggest laugh of our entire career
[Applause]
fell in love they did Jim did fall for
Renee and everyone felt Falls for Renee
when they meet it but she does this
thing where she's like no I'm not I'm
making a movie I'm not I'm not gonna do
it while it do anything while we're
while we're filming so really the energy
that he had it totally worked for our
movie because and also he was playing a
man with you know multiple personalities
so yeah it absolutely energized his
performance no question he because he
was smitten with her
okay your last uh behind the scenes your
solo directorial debut of which I
watched last night with my daughter by
the way champions
[Applause]
you know I've been lucky having worked
with some of the great leading ladies in
all of Hollywood including you okay but
uh
we found a new one here Caitlin Olson is
in this movie and she you might know her
from Always Sunny in Philadelphia yep
she plays in our movie and she is
absolutely terrific I haven't seen this
side of her she's really good we have an
awesome cast you know with Woody
Harrelson and Cheech Marin and Ernie
Hudson and actually
um that's a perfect segue because we're
going to go to a commercial break and
when we come back the cast of Champions
joins us to talk about going viral and
performing at the Super Bowl they'll be
coming out right after this
[Music]